people all around the world are prepared
to celebrate Earth Day it's this Monday
49 years ago in 1970 CBS News covered
the first Earth Day with a special
report hosted by Walter Cronkite au Niq
day in American history is ending a day
set aside for a nationwide outpouring of
mankind seeking its own survival
this year CBS this morning will bring
you a special series of reports on our
changing environment we're calling it
earth matters our team of correspondents
will span the globe to explore what's
being done to protect our cities the
science that shows our planet is
changing and the steps being taken to
protect it and here's a preview on
Vladimir duty in brasilia brazil we are
getting on this plane and heading to the
amazon rainforest where scientists are
studying ways to combat the ravages of
deforestation I'm gonna tell you all
about it that's coming up on Monday
I'm mark Phillips at the British net
office where they don't keep track of
the weather around the world they keep
track of the greenhouse gases that more
and more are causing it coming up next
week it may not look like it but this is
the Rio Grande
I'm Michelle Miller in southern New
Mexico where folks are adapting to what
could become their new normal climate
change that's coming up on CBS this
morning people here in New Delhi have a
saying
breathing kills I'm Elizabeth Palmer and
this city has some of the worst air on
the planet coming up next week we take a
look at the problem and some solutions
i'm debrah powder in Capetown where
people are going
off-grid and embracing solar power we
show you how this energy revolution is
changing live Monday on CBS this morning
I'd watch oh my god really God watch
those people all over the world you're
everywhere that's very nice I know you
had no idea we were doing that something
so comprehensive I can't wait for Monday
it's nice very nice nicely done team
it's done